It's going to be useful to say a little bit
more about the point correspondence problem.
Here we have again the initial view of our
triangular object and here we have the final
view, or the desired view, of our triangle
object.
When the points move in the image plane it's
possible for them to move like this and this
is the example that we just looked at a moment
ago. But it's also possible for the points
to move like this and if they did that then
the motion of the object in three dimensional
space is going to be much more complex. It's
almost going to require the object to flip
around in the three-dimensional world.
Another way we could define the correspondence
is like this and again it involved a different
kind of three-dimensional motion.
And finally we could have this particular
way of point moving on the image plane.
Each different way of associating a yellow
dot with a red dot is going to result in a
different motion in the three-dimensional
world. The net result will be the same in
the image plane but the actual three-dimensional
motion will be different.